the story of Dracula is one that has
been told and retold many times
throughout the years some remain fairly
true to the original whereas others
attempt to place their own unique spin
on the story to varying levels of
success and then we have those where
well the less we say the better I guess
it's time to finally delve into the
story that created one of Fiction's most
infamous characters the work of Bram
Stoker is one of the most well-known
examples of early Gothic horror a genre
that inspired so many writers Dracula
was written by Bram Stoker in the 1890s
and eventually published in
1897 The Narrative consists of a series
of letters journal entries and newspaper
articles there is no singular
protagonist however its characters have
truly stood the test of time and the
novel itself is considered to be one of
the most famous pieces of English
literac richer so join me today as we
cover a true horror classic in Bram
Stoker's
Dracula if you're anything like me and
you enjoy watching or listening to a
good horror story before bed it's
probably not the best idea for a good
night's rest which is why today's video
has been made possible by the awesome
people over at Manta sleep who are
dedicated to making sure that you get
the best sleep possible with a wide
range of sleep masks and sleep
accessories recently I've been
monitoring my own sleep patterns in an
attempt to become more of a functioning
member of society naturally when I saw
how poor my sleep was I decided to try a
sleep mask I've been using the Manta
original sleep mask which does a great
job in blocking out sources of light and
general background and external
annoyances it's also very comfortable to
wear and doesn't place any pressure on
your eyelids and lashes it's easy to
pack up and very portable making it a
great choice for people who travel
there's also a Mass for every occasion
original weighted silk Steam and even a
sound mask with built-in Bluetooth
speakers for those who like to fall
asleep whilst listening to relaxing
music or an audio book that may or may
not be horror themed you can follow the
link on screen right now as well as in
the description of this video to find
out more about achieving better sleep
make sure to use my code MF at checkout
to receive a 10%
discount Jonathan Harker's Journal 3rd
May the Story begins with Jonathan
Harker a newly qualified solicitor
traveling from London to meet a
mysterious new client he travels via
train and passes through Munich Budapest
and Vienna before arriving on the
Eastern outskirts of a country he refers
to as Transylvania he arrives in a town
known as bistritz high up in the Misty
Mountains Parker describes this as one
of the wildest and least known parts of
Europe one would be hardpressed to find
its location on a map of any kind the
mysterious client he waits for is a
nobleman known as Count Dracula who has
expressed interest in purchasing a house
near London the count instructed Harker
to wait for him at the golden Hotel a
rather old-fashioned looking building at
the door he was greeted by an elderly
woman who gave him a letter from Count
Dracula my friend welcome to the
carpathians I am anxiously expecting you
sleep well tonight at 3: tomorrow the
diligence will start for bovina a place
on it is kept for you at the bouro pass
my Carriage will await you and bring you
to me I trust that your journey from
London has been a happy one and that you
will enjoy your stay in my beautiful
land your friend Dracula the letter
welcomes Harker and instructs him to
sleep well as the following day at 3 a
coach will arrive to take him to bovina
where he will find the Count's private
Carriage at the bouro pass 4th of May
Harker departed that following day and
once in the bouro pass he noticed a
carriage pull up beside the coach being
drawn by black horses The Carriage was
being driven by a tall man with a long
brown beard and a tall black hat which
hid his face Harker recalls only being
able to see bright gleaming eyes that
appeared almost red in the lamp lights
the man turned his face to the coach and
smiled remarking that he was early
tonight with help from the driver Harker
climbed into the carriage and they rode
into the darkness the darkness was
broken when the moon peered out from the
thick clouds staring at the Moon Harker
began to panic all of a sudden when he
noticed a pack of Shaggy looking wolves
surrounding the carriage he called out
to the driver who stood up and with one
sweeping motion of his arm almost
signaled to the Wolves to leave slowly
they backed off until the carriage rode
past them the moon was once again
engulfed by the clouds and the Darkness
returned eventually they arrive at the
courtyard of a vast ruined Castle its
tall black windows blocking even a
single ray of sunshine from entering the
carriage came to a stop and before Mr
Harker was a pale old man who invited
him into his home he noted that the
man's touch was cold closer to that of
the Dead than the living Harker
establishes that this man is Dracula he
shows Harker to his room and offers him
supper the count doesn't join Harker
claiming that he had already eaten after
dinner he smokes a cigar given to him by
his host and observes Dracula he finds
the Count's appearance to be rather
strange
a pale old man with wild bushy hair
pointed ears a slender nose with
overarching nostrils A Thin Mustache he
described as evil but what caught his
eye in particular were the sharp teeth
that protruded over his lips which were
a vibrant red not common for someone of
his age his hands were also strange hair
located on his palms and long nails
sharpened to a point his touch caused
Harker to shudder his breath was Rank
and caused his guest to feel nauseous
the cter realizing Harker's discomfort
retreated and told him to sleep in as
late as he desired as he would be away
until the afternoon 7th May exploring
the castle Harker begins to notice more
Oddities despite these surroundings
suggesting the Count's wealth there is
not a single room with a mirror or even
a piece of glass where one's reflection
can be seen
there are no servants and Harker has
seen or heard nothing around the castle
grounds other than the howling of walls
Dracula explains that his love for
England and desire to walk the Streets
of London came from his collection of
books together they sit down and discuss
the details of the estate that he will
be purchasing on the Count's behalf he
is intrigued as to how Mr Harker was
able to find such a perfect match for
him the state is called Carfax and has a
large house on the grounds that is
reminiscent of a medieval keep it's
fairly secluded with only a chapel and a
newly built insane asylum nearby neither
of which were visible from the grounds
the count is pleased that the house is
of an old design as he himself is from
an old
family 8th May homesickness overcomes
Harker the Count's Castle brings him an
uneasy feeling and he begins to wish
that he never came to this place Harker
hung his shaving glass on the window and
began to shave good morning startled by
the Count's greeting he had cut himself
when he looked back at his shaving glass
to look at his cut there was no
reflection of the man just over his
shoulder the blood from the cut ran down
his neck and before he could wipe it
away he saw the Count's demeanor change
an uncontrollable Fury had come over him
and as he reached for Harker's neck as
Harker pulled away the Count's hand
brushed against the crucifix around his
neck and the almost possessed trance the
count was in quickly disappeared the
count warns him to take care as cutting
himself in this country is more
dangerous than he can imagine he took
the Shaving glass and threw it out the
window blaming the man-made mirror for
Harker's accident before retreating
without a word after breakfast Harker
explored the castle some more he began
to realize that almost every door was
bolted shut the only way out was through
a window and thus he believes this
Castle is a prison and he is the
prisoner 9th May midnight in an attempt
to learn more of this country Harker
asks the count about Transylvanian
history the count describes the battles
in great detail almost as if he was
there he took pride in describing the
dracul bloodline as great great Heroes
with accolades that none of the other
families could boast 16th May Harker
questions whether he has lost his sanity
praying to God to save him before it's
too late the prior night a Sleepless
Harker roam the castle and when looking
out of a window he saw the Count's head
peering out of another window he was
lost for words when the count climbed
out of the window and began to crawl
down the castle walls head first no man
could do this at this point Harker was
convinced that the count must be a
creature in the form of a man watching
him leave the grounds now was his chance
to explore more than he had ever dared
with his lamp he frantically checked all
the doors but they were locked as
expected at the end of a Stairway he
found a door that although locked he was
able to push open when applying pressure
this area of the castle seemed more
modern than the rest and Harker found it
comforting enough to sit down and
recount the events thus far in his
journal Harker fell asleep in this room
and when he woke across from him with
three young ladies in dresses despite
the Moonlight shining behind them they
cast no shadow on the floor they
approached and stared at Harker for some
time before Whispering amongst each
other two of the women had dark hair a
nose that resembled the count and eyes
that were red The Other Woman was
slightly paler with flowing gold locks
of hair and eyes that resembled pale
sapphires the pale woman resembled
someone Harker knew or had seen before
he wasn't quite sure where or how it all
felt like a dream they began to laugh
and encourage the blonde woman to step
forward you go first and we shall follow
they said this one is young and strong
there are kisses for us all the blond
woman lent in and her teeth pressed
against Harker's neck before she could
sink them in Harker opened his eyes and
felt the presence of the count his eyes
as red as before he grabbed the woman by
her neck and flung her across the room
the count was furious with his arm he
motioned them back as the driver had
done with the Wolves how dare you touch
him how dare you lay eyes upon him when
I had forbidden it he growled this man
belongs to me I promise you when I am
done with him you may kiss him at your
will are we to have nothing tonight they
asked the count he responded by pointing
at a bag that he had thrown on the floor
a bag that twitched as if it contained a
small living being one of the women
opened the bag and smiled Harker heard
what he believed to have been the
moaning of a newborn child the three
women surrounded the bag and Harker
looked away for a brief second when he
turned back they disappeared with the
bag he thought he saw the remnant of
their ghostly shape outside of the
window the shock and horror of what had
just happened was too much for Harker he
slumped back into his chair and passed
out 19th May the count asked Mr Harker
to write three letters one stating that
his business with the count was almost
concluded and he will begin his journey
home in a few days the second the
following morning stating that he had
left the third letter stating that he
had left the castle and arrived safely
in bit he asked the count what dates he
should use for the letters the first
should be June 12 the 2 June 19 and the
3rd June 29 to Harker the answer the
count gave signal to him how long he
would have left before the count would
end his life 17th June on this morning
Harker heard two wagons enter the castle
grounds despite his best efforts they
ignored his calls for help and refused
to even look in his Direction the
drivers were busy unloading large crates
with rope handles he guessed the boxes
were empty judging by how easy they were
being handled 21st June the prior night
the count had locked himself in his
chamber Harker could hear the cries of a
woman pleading with the count to give
her back her child he could not see the
woman but he could hear the beating of
her hands on the door from high above
the count called out in a harsh whisper
and this was soon met by the howling of
wolves soon the woman was surrounded by
them however there were no screams from
her almost as if she had accepted her
fate Parker did not witness her demise
but he saw the Wolves leaving the
courtyard licking their lips 29th June
this is the day Harker believed to be
his last he had to try and escape on the
south side of the castle he climbed out
of a window and made his way along the
ledge to the Count's room he opened the
window and to his surprise he slid into
what was an empty room there was a large
door that opened to a stone passage
leading to a circular stairway that went
down here Harker found an old chapel
that was once used as a graveyard the
Earth here had been dug up and placed
into boxes similar to those that were
delivered earlier in one of those boxes
laying on the newly dug Earth was the
count Eyes Wide Open Harker could not
tell if he was asleep or dead there was
no pulse or breathing however his
appearance was not what Harker had
become accustomed to the White's hair
and mustache were now dark gray his skin
was more red than pale and his cheeks
seemed Fuller his mouth also had more
color with fresh blood still on his lips
trickling down his chin and neck half
felt the overwhelming desire to rid the
world of this terrible monster he took a
shovel the Workman had used to fill the
boxes lifted it above his head and then
plunged it down at the Count's face as
he did the Count's eyes opened and his
head turned his attempt to kill the
count failed as he missed falling over
and dropping the shovel he could hear
the songs of the Workman returning and
so he fled to the Count's room he could
hear the boxes being n nailed down and
moved most likely being transported onto
the wagons which he could also hear
leaving the courtyard he was now alone
in the castle with the three women from
before he planned to once again scale
the castle and find a way out of this
cursed place the fall is steep and would
surely kill him if he fell but Harker
would rather the mercy of God than to
remain in this hell he ends this journal
entry by saying goodbye by
all 24th July Whitby it's at this point
in the narrative we swap to the Journal
of mina Murray the woman who is engaged
to Jonathan Harker Mina meets with her
friend Lucy and they discuss Lucy's
upcoming marriage from having no
interest shown in her Lucy had three men
proposed to her on the same day Arthur
Homewood Quincy Morris and John Seward
all three men were good friends and Lucy
accepted the proposal of Arthur this
turns Mina's mind to Jonathan whom she
hadn't heard from in a month 8th August
there was a terrible storm that night
Lucy who would occasionally Sleepwalk
had done so several times and Mina had
put her back to bed in the morning Mina
had heard news of a boat that was
wrecked at the harbor a Russian ship
named the demer when the boat reached
the shore a large dog Le from below and
r across the harbor the boat was not
particularly large with only a small
amount of cargo great wooden boxes
filled with mold on board they had found
a dead man tied to the Helm of the ship
holding a crucifix in possession of a
bottle inside of the bottle was the
deer's log detailing the journey from
Vana to Whitby written July 18th things
so strange are happening that I shall
keep accurate notes henceforth until we
land the journey started on July 6th
When the boxes of dirt were loaded onto
the ship the crew was made up of five
hands two mates a cook and the captain
himself who wrote The Log the first week
of their Journey was uneventful with a
few Customs checks regarding their cargo
July 13th is when the captain first
notes the crew dissatisfied about
something but appeared too scared to
speak out July 16th the first roommate
petrovski had gone missing the captain
had sailed with these men many times and
had never seen them this down however
they would not voice their concern the
only thing the captain and his first
mates could gather was that they felt
something was on board July 17th one of
the men algarin came to the captain's
cabin to confide in him he had seen a
strange man aboard a tall thin man that
did not match the appearance of any of
the crew he attempted to follow the man
but he just disappeared Into Thin Air
which confused and scared old Garin July
14th another man had disappeared he had
finished his watch and was never seen
again the crew asked to have a double
watch instead of a single so they could
feel safe in numbers July 29th there was
only a single watch that evening as the
crew were too tired for a double when
morning came the watch found no one on
Deck other than the steeran meaning
another man had gone missing July 30th
the ship is nearing England and the
captain slept soundly until he was woken
with the news that the two men on Watch
and the steeran had all gone missing
only the captain his mate and two crew
remained second August the captain was
woken from a brief sleep by screams on
Deck they found nobody another man had
been taken 3rd August the captain had to
relieve the man at wheel but found no
one he called for his first mate who
rushed to the deck it was only them
remaining his first mate came close and
whispered it is here I know it now on
the watch last night I saw it tall and
thin and ghastly pale it was in the
boughs and looking out I crept behind it
and gave it my knife but the knife went
through it empty as the air but it is
here and I'll find it it is in the hold
perhaps in one of the boxes I'll unscrew
them one by one and see the captain
could only assume his first mate had
gone mad he could hear him knocking
around below searching the boxes all of
a sudden he made his way to the dock
screaming wide-eyed and full of fear
save me save me he cried you had better
come too Captain before it's too late he
is here I know the secret now the sea
will save me from him and that is all
that is left before the captain could
move his first mate threw himself into
the sea the captain believed his first
mate had gone mad and so he must have
been responsible for the other men at
least now he had joined them August 4th
the captain too scared to go below
remained at the helm it was here he
finally saw the man God forgive me but
the matate was right to jump overboard
it was best to die like a man to die
like a sailor in the Blue Water no man
can object but I am captain and I must
not leave my ship I shall baffle the
fiend or Monster I shall tie my hands to
the wheel when my strength begins to
fail and along with them I shall tie
that which he it does not dare to touch
and then come good wind or foul I shall
save my soul and honor as Captain the
captain Captain placed his log in a
bottle so it may be found if the ship
was wrecked the authorities found no
evidence and could not confirm the
captain's story The Local saw the
captain as a hero deserving of a public
funeral tomorrow will see the funeral
and so will end this one more mystery of
the
sea 11th August 3:00 a.m. unable to
sleep Mina notices that Lucy was not in
her bed and so she began looking for her
looking across the pier she saw a figure
in white in the distance that she
thought must have been Lucy there was a
dark figure behind her Mina could not
work out if this was a man or a creature
and so she made her way over with haste
she called out to Lucy but she did not
answer a face did turn towards her one
with gleaming red eyes Mina lost sight
of Lucy as she ran through the chapel
between them when she found Lucy she was
still sleeping but she was Breathing
heavily Mina took Lucy and rushed home
there was no sight of the dark figure
that she had seen earlier 19th August
Mina had received a letter on behalf of
Jonathan from a hospital in Budapest the
letter was from a sister Agatha and
stated that Mr Harker had been in their
care for 6 weeks suffering from a
violent brain fever the letter talks of
Jonathan's delirium ranting about ghosts
and wolves demons blood and poison
Jonathan's employer Mr Hawkings had
suggested that she meet Jonathan in
Budapest to nurse him back to health
perhaps even to marry him the next
journal entry comes from a doctor Seward
the administrator of the insane asylum
next to Carfax Dracula's new home 10th
August Dr seard had proposed to Lucy but
she turned him down for someone else and
so he turned his Focus to his work he
had picked out a patient that he found
so strange and unlike the normal lunatic
that he was determined to try and
understand him the patient was called RM
Renfield he was of sanguine temperament
which described someone who is
enthusiastic and overt talk ative he was
of great physical strength and went
through bouts of morbid excitement
followed by periods of Gloom 19th August
Dr Seward noticed a sudden change in
Renfield the prior evening the night
Watchman had alerted him that Renfield
had escaped Seward could see Renfield
scaling the wall that separated the
Asylum and Carfax estate he instructed
the night Watchman to send for three or
four men to help restrain Renfield he
then climbed over the wall himself and
gave Chase into Carfax he found Renfield
outside of the old chapel whispering to
himself I am here to do your bidding
master I am your slave and you shall
reward me they managed to restrain
Renfield who struggled at first but all
of a sudden was completely calm Seward
looked around to see what could have
caused this change but could only see
Renfield staring up at the Moon focused
on a bat flapping its wings in the
distance Renfield was calm enough now
that he went willingly back to the
Asylum but Seward found this change in
demeanor slightly concerning 31st August
Arthur writes to Dr Seward informing him
that Lucy is unwell and he would
appreciate if he attended her Arthur was
summoned to see his father who himself
was very sick 2nd September Dr Seward
writes to Arthur letting him know that
he cannot quite diagnose Lucy he
believes the condition to be mental
trouble breathing and dreams which
frighten her dreams that she cannot
remember Dr SE reached out to his old
professor in Amsterdam Dr Van Hing an
expert in strange and obscure diseases
7th September when Dr seard explained
Lucy's symptoms to Dr Van Hing he looked
alarmed but said nothing this time when
Dr Seward saw Lucy she looked even worse
she was Gastly pale she had lost all
color in her lips and cheeks the bones
in her face were extremely visible and
she struggled to breathe after examining
Lucy Van Hing identified that without
about a blood transfusion she would die
very soon due to loss of blood one of
them would have to volunteer and as Dr
seard was much younger he offered his
blood to save Lucy Arthur soon arrived
to meet the two men having received the
Letter's deeply concern for his fiance
willing to do anything he offered his
blood van heling gave Luc a narcotic to
put her to sleep and began the operation
as Arthur grew weaker Lucy's color was
restored the transfusion was a success
tending to Lucy Professor van Hing
noticed a red mark around her neck over
her jugular vein there were two small
punctures Dr Seward could not give his
Professor an answer as to what these
marks were but van Hing seemed to have
an idea Dr Seward was to remain and
watch over Lucy all night Professor van
Hing was to return to Amsterdam and
retrieve books and items he required
when he returned they would begin but
begin what exactly he did not say 12th
September Dr seard recounts an incident
where Renfield broke out of his room and
made his way to Carfax Abbey once again
this time he came across a cart carrying
large wooden boxes he attacks one of the
men driving the cart but Dr seard was
able to intervene if he hadn't done so
he had no doubt Renfield could have
killed the man 18th September Dr seard
and Professor van heling arrived at
Lucy's estate and entered her room where
they found both Lucy and her mother
laying on her bed both pale and
motionless they rushed Lucy into another
room and Van Hing was adamant that it
wasn't too late for Lucy but they would
have to perform another transfusion
luckily Quincy Morris was there to
volunteer with his transfusion Lucy
symptoms began to improve for the time
being on Lucy the professor had found a
note that that he gave to Dr Seward
memorandum left by Lucy Weston ra
September 17th in this note Lucy
recounts the events that transpired
after the night she was saved by Mina
when sleepwalking she recalls hearing
howling outside of her bedroom window
when she went to check she saw nothing
more than a large bat knocking against
her window her mother came to check if
she was all right and laid in bed with
her the howling continued as did the
knocking of the bat all of a sudden
there was a loud crash and glass from
the window shattered all over the floor
behind the window was the head of a
large gray wolf her mother took the reef
of flowers that Professor van Hing
insisted Lucy wore around her neck she
pointed at the wolf before falling over
Lucy had no idea what had happened to
her mother it was almost as if she was
struck by lightning her attempts to wake
her were in vain as she must have lost
Consciousness unable to remember any
anything else when she woke she could
still hear the wolves howling however
this time it was accompanied by the
howls of the neighboring dogs Lucy ends
the note by saying goodbye to Arthur not
expecting to survive the night after
reading the note Dr Seward was more
confused than ever looking to Professor
van Hing for answers had Lucy gone
completely insane or was she truly in
some kind of terrible danger 19th
September professor vanel and Dr Seward
when examining Lucy noticed that the
wounds on her neck had completely
disappeared Professor van heling told Dr
seard that it was time for Arthur to see
his fiance's face one final time as it
was clear their attempts had failed and
she was dying observing this interaction
they noticed Lucy's teeth appeared
longer and sharper her voice less frail
and more seductive as she asked Arthur
to kiss her Dr Seward taken back by this
Sudden Change could only watch on as
Professor van heling hurled himself
forward and grabbed Arthur not for your
life not for your living soul and hers
he screamed as he pulled Arthur away
after a brief spasm of Rage she returned
to the Lucy of old she took van hing's
hand and asked him to look over Arthur
to which he gave his word Arthur gave
Lucy one final kiss on her forehead and
her breathing stopped it is all over she
is dead Van Helen confirmed Arthur left
the room and Dr Seward turned to the
professor at least it is over she can
rest this is the end the professor with
a grim look on his face shook his head
no I am afraid not this is only the
beginning Dr seard asked him what he
meant but the professor's answer was
that they could do nothing as of right
now they would have to wait and see Mina
Harker's Journal 22nd September
Jonathan's recovery was slow and Mina
had just heard news of Lucy and her
mother's death from Professor van heling
they had both already been buried and
Van heling would make his way to mina in
the coming days 27th September Dr
Seward's diary Professor van Hing
presented Dr Seward with a newspaper
article about children and small
puncture wounds similar to that of Lucy
he asked Dr seard if he thought the
person responsible for Lucy's wounds was
also responsible for what had happened
to those children Dr seard thought it
was most definitely a possibility but
like so many of the questions the
professor asked he already knew the
answer when Professor vaning revealed
that the puncture wounds on the children
were in fact made by Lucy Dr Seward was
stunned the professor could see Dr seard
was still apprehensive and so tomorrow
evening he would prove it to him along
with Arthur and Quincy Morris 29th
September morning the night prior just
before 10:00 van heling explained to the
three men what must be done he asked
Arthur for his permission to act as he
feels best he asked them to accompany
him to the churchyard where Lucy was
buried there they would enter the tomb
Arthur understandably struggled with
what was being requested but managed to
compose himself when they were inside
the tomb they would open the coffin to
examine whether she was Undead arthurus
took this to mean that there was a
chance Lucy was buried alive but
Professor van heling reiterated that he
did not say Lucy was alive but there
still was a chance that she was Undead
this was not something the professor
wanted to do but he would need Arthur
with him and with a clear mind
struggling to understand he accepted the
professor's proposal they would arrive
at the churchyard just before a quarter
to 12 and the professor began searching
for Lucy's coffin he unscrewed the lid
and with a tiny sword began to cut
through the lead beneath the professor
continued and when he was through the
lead he opened the coffin and all three
men were shocked when they saw that the
coffin was empty Professor van heling
ordered everyone outside and Clos the
door to the tomb behind him he then
placed a seal outside of the Tomb so the
undead may not enter all four then
waited out out side of the Tomb for some
time before seeing a figure in white
they could not see her face but it was a
dark-haired woman dressed in what looked
like funeral G the figure was bent down
over a child a small cry could be heard
and all three men prepared to intervene
the professor gested for them to stay
where they were as the figure came
closer close enough for them to
recognize the figure as Lucy Professor
van Hing took a step forward his Lantern
revealing Lucy's lips covered in fresh
blood the figure before them was Lucy in
appearance only her warm and friendly
demeanor was coldblooded and lifeless
her eyes filled with fiery rage she
snarled at The Men Who approached her
threw the child to the ground and
approached Arthur with outstretched arms
with his face hidden in his hands Arthur
did his best to ignore her call come my
husband and we shall rest together
Arthur appeared to be under a spell with
Open Hands he made his way towards her
van heling placed himself between the
two and held up his golden crucifix
causing Lucy to recoil at the mere sight
she made her way to the tomb but the
seal worked and she could not enter she
turned around and found herself trapped
between the seal and Van hing's crucifix
the professor called out to Arthur
answer me my friend am I to proceed in
my work Arthur fall to his knees
covering his face again instructed the
professor to do as he will the professor
removed the seal from the tomb and
somehow Lucy was able to slide through a
gap that no Corporal body should have
been able to Professor van heling
unlocked the door to the tomb and was
followed in by all three men this time
when they took off the lid to Lucy's
coffin they saw her body Arthur began to
acknowledge that this was not his
beloved Lucy professor Professor van
heling opened his bag and removed the
tools he would need Dr Seward noticing a
stake and Hammer among many other things
he explained to the men that the undead
could not die they were to live for
eternity and all those who fell victim
to them would also become Undead the
professor recommended that it should be
Arthur to set Lucy free he was to place
a stake over her heart and strike with
the hammer once the prayer to the dead
was complete the professor began to read
and when the time was right Arthur
lifted the hammer and struck down
piercing Lucy's heart with the stake
Lucy sat up and began to wrie in pain
biting down on her lips as blood
spattered from the heart Arthur did not
falter and after a brief struggle the
figure stopped and fell back into the
coffin when they looked down they saw
the Lucy they had known not the
distorted Abomination she had become
Arthur kissed her goodbye one more time
and left the tomb with Quincy the
professor and Dr Seward however still
had work to do they left the steak in
the body and cut off the head filling it
with garlic before closing the coffin
and soldering the lid shut they returned
to the Barkley hotel where a telegram
was waiting for the professor it was
from Mina she had important news and was
on a train home accompanied by Jonathan
30th September me and Jonathan returned
to London and together using all of
Jonathan's diary entries they pieced
together the information regarding the
boxes that had been transported to
Carfax Dr Seward surprised that the
house Dracula had purchased was the one
right next to his very own Asylum
relayed this information to Professor
van heling the professor confirmed the
existence of vampires making it known
the one on their doorstep is extremely
powerful he has the strength of 20 men
he can speak with the dead he can take
many forms from animal to mist he can
control the weather and is more cunning
than any man they have encountered
before despite a list that describes
Dracula as all powerful he does have
limitations he cannot enter a household
unless he has been invited in he can
only cross running water at the lowest
point of the tide his power is endless
in the night but at the coming of day it
is very limited certain things can
render him powerless such as garlic and
the crucifix it is the blood of the
living that sustains him if they confine
him to his coffin then maybe they can
stop him the first task was to discover
how many of the boxes that had been
transported remained in Carfax a task
deemed too dangerous for mina she would
remain safe while the rest of the men
entered the
estate Dr Steward's diary 1st October
last night they made their way to Carfax
using the Shadows of the trees to remain
undetected the professor using a
skeleton key was able to open the front
door October 2nd it was agreed that Dr
Seward would visit Thomas Snelling the
man who Renfield attacked transporting
the boxes at his home Mr Snelling told
Dr Seward he had made two Journeys from
Carfax and a house in Picadilly he had
taken 21 boxes from Carfax to this other
house after a small payment he provided
the address to the house in Picadilly
the professor was pleased with Dr
Seward's work he made it clear that
before they attempt to kill the count
they must locate all of the boxes that
came from
Transylvania October 3rd Dr seard was
alerted that there had been an accident
involving Renfield he found him lying in
a pool of his own blood when Dr SE and
Professor van heling examined Renfield
he told them that he had had a terrible
dream Renfield acknowledges that he is
dying and what he experienced may have
been reality and not a dream before he
died he wished to tell Dr Seward
something to ease his burden at his
window he saw Dracula but this time it
felt less like a dream like the count
was actually there and so Renfield
invited him in without noticing Renfield
continued Ling and revealed that the
count had been feeding on Mina Harker
they hurried to the Harker's residence
and burst into their bedroom where
Jonathan lay on the bed in distress and
standing at the foot of the bed was his
wife Mina and a skinny stranger dressed
in black when they saw his face they all
immediately knew the stranger was indeed
the count who had one hand gripped
tightly around both of Mina's hands and
the other hand wrapped around her neck
forcing her to feed from him when he
noticed them burst into the room he
threw minor against the bed and pounced
on the men before him professor vanh
heling had with him the sacred wafer the
count halted and coward at the sight of
it slowly moving backwards with their
crucifixes held aoft the men continued
walking towards the count the moon was
covered in dark clouds and with this the
count of vanished into thick Vapor Mina
let out a blood curdling scream which
woke Jonathan seeing the blood trickle
down her mouth he turned to Dr Seward
and Professor van Hing for answers the
professor turned to Mina and asked her
to explain what had happened Mina woke
and could feel the presence of someone
when she turned to Jonathan she could
not wake him regardless of how hard she
tried turning back there was a man all
dressed in black with glowing red eyes
standing beside her bed she described
him as almost appearing from the Mist
given the description she had heard
heard from others she knew this must
have been the count on his forehead was
a red SCAR Where Jonathan had struck him
pointing at Jonathan the count spoke to
mina silence if you make a sound I shall
take him and dash his brains out before
your very eyes Mina helpless could only
listen as the count placed one hand on
her shoulder and revealed her neck with
the other first a little refreshment to
reward my exer
he said with a grin before telling Mina
it wasn't the first time or the second
that her veins had appeased his thirst
he placed his lips on her throat and
began to drink as he did she felt her
strength fading away Mina had lost her
sense of time but felt that there must
have been a significant amount that
passed before the count spoke again the
count expressed his annoyance that she
would help these men in their plan to
stop him she would have to be punished
whenever the count called to her she
would cross land or sea to do his
bidding the count opened his shirt and
with his long sharp nails he opened a
vein in his chest when the blood began
to spurt out he took her by the neck and
pressed her face against his chest
leaving her no choice but to swallow the
blood or suffocate Jonathan Harker's
Journal 3rd October in the morning the
men convened where they discussed
destroying the count slay before leaving
Professor van heling took the sacred
wafer he had used to repel Dracula and
planned on using it to protect Mina as
he began his Blessing it was cut short
when Mina screamed the wafer seared the
Flesh on her forehead Mina took this to
mean she was now sullied and unclean she
was becoming more and more like the
count the newly form scar was proof that
God had forsaken her professor van
heling comforted Mina there was still
hope that they may see the day when the
red Scar left from the wafer would
disappear Jonathan kissed his fiance and
the men left for Carfax they entered
CARFAX without any resistance the
professor opened one of the boxes and
placed the sacred wafer on the soil
before closing the Box ensuring to leave
no evidence that it had been tampered
with they followed van hing's lead
making sure the boxes were left as they
were found with the success at Carfax
there was still hope for mina as long as
they were able to place the wafer in the
other boxes at the house in Picadilly
when they entered the house at Picadilly
the stench was just as bad as Carfax and
it was clear the count had been using
this house freely in the dining room
they found 20 boxes of Earth they were
expecting 21 and so they now had a new
problem all of this was meaningless if
they could not locate the last missing
box
they treated the boxes in the dining
room just as they did the ones back at
Carfax as the count did not already
appear to be in the house they decided
to wait for his return late in the
afternoon they heard a key opening the
door they waited but the footsteps were
slow the count must have either known
that they were there or he was fearful
of the possibility without warning the
count Le past them before they could
even react he Beed his teeth and snarled
Jonathan took his knife and made a lunge
towards the count any normal man would
have been impaled but the count was too
quick and was able to LEAP backwards
Jonathan had only managed to cut his
pocket from which some Bank notes and
gold fell to the floor the count scooped
up what he could and threw himself
towards the window he crashed through
the window and landed below unharmed he
ran towards the stable and turned back
to Jonathan and the other men before
before leaving he told them that their
women were his and they would do his
bidding the count had escaped and
Jonathan returned to mina during the
night Mina woke Jonathan requesting that
he call Professor vanh heling as she had
to speak with him urgently a few minutes
later everyone was summoned and the
professor was in the room still in his
night gown Mina's plan was for the
professor to hypnotize her so she could
speak freely without the Count's
influence perhaps they could use the
connection between the count and Mina to
find the location of the last box
Professor van heling was successful and
began to ask Mina questions she did not
know where she was she could only see
Darkness but could hear the lapping of
water the professor was able to deduce
that she was describing being on a ship
of some kind unfortunately that was all
the information van heling was able to
retrieve before sending Mina back to to
sleep when Mina woke the professor
explained that after the Count's close
encounter with them he must have fled to
a ship with the hopes of escaping back
to his home with his last box October
5th 5:00 p.m. when they reconvened the
professor had already located the ship
that the count planned to use as the
count would naturally return to
Transylvania the ship must have been
bound for the Black Sea this narrowed
the search down to one the ship had
already left the temps the prior morning
to complete the journey would take 3
weeks even at the fastest speed they
could make the same Journey on land
within 3 days this would allow them more
than enough time to arm themselves and
prepare their plan of attack Dr Seward's
diary 15th October using the Orient
Express they arrived at their
destination and began the wait for the
count ship to dock a week of waiting and
there was nothing to show the professor
feared that the count might just be
escaping them 28th October finally there
was news of the Count's ship arriving
however it was arriving in a different
location just as van heling had used
Mina to gather information on the
Count's plan the count had also used
Mina to learn of their plan and make the
necessary changes to evade them 30th
October they had Tracked Down the ship
and spoke to the captain he had been
paid to deliver the boxes Before Sunrise
in order to avoid Customs he gave the
box to a Petrov skinsky who dealt with a
Slovac who traded down at the Port that
was all the captain knew with that
information they returned to mina
frustrated the box was traveling
somewhere by water but they had no idea
where Mina Harker's Journal 30th October
Mina was able to examine the map she was
given and found the route that traveled
through the bouro path and as close to
Dracula's castle as possible Jonathan
and the professor were thrilled that
there was hope again now that the count
believed he had thrown them off his
Trail Arthur was to follow the count
with a steamboat Mr Morris was to follow
from behind with horses just in case he
tried to land Professor vanh heling was
concerned about Petro as he would surely
be armed but the men themselves were in
possession of a small Arsenal Mina was
to remain with the professor who would
watch over her they would instead travel
to Dracula's castle whilst he was
occupied Jonathan given his past
experience in Dracula's castle was not
pleased with the professor's plan but he
was adamant that this was the only way
to save
Mina November 1st the professor and Mina
traveled by Carriage to Dracula's castle
hypnotizing Mina once again he was able
to confirm that Dracula was still on the
water November 5th van heling and Mina
were close to the castle as they set up
camp for the night the professor drew a
ring around Mina sprinkling the sacred
wafer to protect her all of a sudden
three women appeared from a bright white
light the women were dressed in long
flowing gowns looking at their teeth and
volumptuous red lips the professor knew
that these were the same three women
Jonathan had described to him the women
laughed and called out to Mina come
sister come join us Mina was not yet one
of their kind she resisted their calls
and the professor hope that her soul
could still be saved only grew as the
sun began to rise van heling recalls the
horrid figur melting in the mist and
snow van heling left Mina resting in the
circle and made his way to the castle
Jonathan's description allowed the
professor to find the chapel with ease
and begin his work having having seen
the three women he searched for their
graves van heling found the first but he
also found himself being slowly overcome
with Fascination the vampire alur that
he described as taking the lives of so
many with a gust of wind came a low
scream from Mina who woke the professor
from this spell he continued on and
found the graves of all three sisters
there was one more grave larger and more
noble looking than the others engraved
on it was one word Dracula he placed
some of the wafer in Dracula's tomb and
turned his Focus to the women to begin
his terrible task he struggled with the
ACT he described as Butchery the screams
of one vampire he could handle but three
may have been too far for even him the
thought of freeing their souls and
allowing them to finally rest gave him
the strength he needed to free all three
women just as he had done with Lucy with
his task complete and Dracula now unable
to return to his tomb van heling
returned to Mina and they both set off
eastwards to meet their friends before
reuniting with their companions van Hing
and Mina spotted a group of carts being
driven by what Mina described as gypsies
or peasants with them was Dracula's CR
the gypsies were riding at Breakneck
speed they were racing against the
sunset behind them van Hing saw two men
on horses giving Chase Jonathan and
Arthur the professor readied his rifle
and mea her revolver the howling of
wolves could be heard from all sides
surrounded on all sides Jonathan called
the gypsies to Halt the leader gave his
men the word and they drew their weapons
Quincy and Dr Seward joined Jonathan and
Arthur as they leapt from their horses
and went straight for Dracula's cart
neither the pistols and knives raed by
the gypsies or the howling of wolves
were enough to distract them from their
mission Jonathan made his way through
unharmed Quincy however parried away the
knives being lunged in his Direction but
one must have found its way through
together Jonathan and Quincy were able
to pry open the lid of the crate the
gypsies had all but given up as they
were surrounded and offered no more
resistance the count lay in his crate
waiting for the sun to set he would soon
be full strength Jonathan slashed at the
Count's throat and Quincy plunged his
Bowie knife into his heart before their
eyes the Count's entire body crumbled
into dust and disappeared the gypsies
rode off and were followed by the Wolves
now alone Mina and Van heling rushed to
their friends Quincy remained upbeat
despite knowing that he would die from
the knife wound before the sun set its
Rays illuminated Mina's face and they
could see the color had been restored
Quincy was happy that he could have been
of service and his death was worth being
able to lift the curse from
Mina note from Jonathan Harker Jonathan
recounts the events that had happened 7
years ago the happiness was worth the
pain they had to endure Jonathan and
Mina had a son who was born on the same
day that Quincy Morris died Mina
believed that some part of Quincy's soul
is with them son and so he was named
after their Brave friend Dr Seward and
Arthur were both happily married and had
started a families of their own the book
ends with Jonathan stating that no one
would ever believe their wild story van
Hing Comforts them by saying it doesn't
matter that they have no proof and that
no one would believe them one day their
son will grow up and know what a brave
and Gallant woman his mother is and he
will understand why so many risked
everything to save
[Music]
her